we're going to begin with this a news is
not good from the Midwest where parts of
the Midwest are crippled by days of
historic flooding and they are bracing
for even more rain and that's the last
thing they need at least 15 states are
under flood watches and warnings this
morning three deaths are blamed on the
flooding thousands of acres of farmland
are under water
countless livestock are dead estimates
of the damage to the public
infrastructure homes and businesses
soared to more than listen to this
number 524 million dollars and that's
just in the state of Nebraska Vice
President Mike Pence surveyed flooded
areas around Omaha yesterday 84 cities
in the state issued emergency
declarations pence promised quick action
on aid Don Dahler spoke with farmers who
have been hit hard by the disaster and
he's in Waterloo Nebraska Don good
morning
good morning let me show you the real
power of this flood this bridge as you
can see from above is completely wiped
out it's one of a dozen across the state
that have met such fate hundreds of
miles of roads and highways are
impassable as you said the impact on the
state's infrastructure is estimated at
half a billion dollars but you know what
there's also an impact on lives and
livelihood farmers have lost thousands
of their animals and there is a real
concern now that they might not be able
to get back into the fields in time for
their spring plantings what did you
expect to see when you got back here
after the flood receded honest I didn't
expect to see nothing alive seven feet
of water covered Doug and Eric Albert's
nine acre Fremont Nebraska farm in just
minutes when we came in with the boat
and who's still five foot deep the
father and son returned to find a
business they've worked a build for
three years nearly destroyed
how many hogs did you have before the
flooding came we probably lost right at
700 head how many do you think you've
been able to save 14 14 out of 700
the historic flooding is creating
similar scenes of devastation across the
region just a few miles north of the
Albert's farm Tom Geisler his son Joey
say it will be months before their 200
acre farm will be cleaned up and
operating I mean is there a chance that
you're not gonna get the crops in in
time or you think you can be able be
delayed there's no doubt about that
estimated losses for farms and ranches
could reach 1 billion dollars a hard
blow for a group already struggling with
falling incomes rising bankruptcies and
the impact of trade wars director of
agriculture in Nebraska Steve Wellman
says the extensive damage to roads and
bridges will affect consumers across the
country thirty percent of our products
from from Nebraska are exported each
year you're looking at a delay if
nothing else of getting product from
Nebraska not to the consumers back on
the Albert farm insurance will cover
some but not all of the costs they hope
to be able to sell pigs again by next
year if you know most people around here
you're gonna pick up you're gonna start
all over and go from there livestock
feed is being trucked in from other
states because a lot of the feet here is
waterlogged and farmers are desperate to
feed their animals it is expected to
warm up that's not necessarily good news
because that means more snow melts and
more flooding
bianna Don it's clear it's going to be a
long recovery for these hard-working
farmers can't get over those images Don
thank you